all right the PS Vita system is out I'll
leaving give this an intro because it is
a review
[Music]
all right the PS Vita otherwise known as
the most powerful handheld bastard out
there that was on the fence about the PS
Vita I was like yeah it's powerful it's
out there now but what does it have that
I don't already have then I found out
about a few features that Sony wants to
do and I was like alright that's
compelling as hell I'll look into that
now I have one first of all let's do the
boring stuff I mean how does it look the
PS Vita actually looks really good it
looks like ps3 graphics I know it's not
ps3 graphics and it's easy to hide flaws
when the screens smaller but if you hide
them well and it ends up looking like
PlayStation 3 graphics well then it
looks like PlayStation 3 graphics and
I'm satisfied I'm gonna downloaded the
demo to Rayman and it looks good I mean
the colors really snap out it yeah I got
Uncharted golden Abyss with it and it
plays and looks just like Uncharted
that's another review for another time
I'll review that game later this is all
about the system ladies and gentlemen
even the interface I like you know I
mean it's not that boring ass interface
at the PSP and the ps3 half of it it's a
bad interface I mean I'd be fine if it's
like a DOS interface that works but the
fact is I've seen the other one for like
eight years I need something else now
now I have something else
it runs multiple applications at a time
I heard it doesn't do music while you're
playing games which that's a bummer I
haven't tried that yet though but I feel
like that's something you can fix with a
patch so it'll probably be fixed it
should be fixed if you can't play music
while you're playing a game dude
seriously come on fix that and I'm glad
it has dual analog sticks although the
analog sticks are kind of tiny and the
battery life all right you know how this
stuff goes the more powerful the system
the shorter the battery life is just
reality battery life for the PlayStation
Vita actually is a lot longer than the
3ds but what really jumped out at me was
the concept of what Sony wants to do
with the PS Vita that's what really made
me go dude all right yeah like I saw
this commercial this dude was playing an
MLB game on his Playstation 3 then he
pauses it picks up his Vita unpause does
it on their picks up where he left off
and then he goes to work right there I
was like whoa wait what is this madness
tagline game-changer yeah it lives up to
that [ __ ] if that's real so the concept
is cross play if you have the
PlayStation 3 version of a game and the
PlayStation Vita version of the game you
can play it on the PlayStation 3 and
then pause it on there if you need to go
somewhere like the store or something I
don't know why you'd be playing it if
you have to drive to the store that is
dangerous ladies and gentlemen but yeah
I guess you can do it pick it up on your
PlayStation Vita
go somewhere else and it picks up right
where you left off problem is only a
couple games support this right now
I can't tell you the details other than
what I've heard from Sony and that is
yeah it's cool we want to do that and
we're working on it
that's paraphrase it's not an exact
quote but you know supposedly though
they want to push to where you only have
to buy one version of the game you buy
the PlayStation 3 version you can
download the PS Vita version now you
have it now you can cross play which I
feel like that is the coolest thing I've
ever heard of in my life I just feel
like more games should support that
though like okay you got Ultimate Marvel
vs. Capcom 3 for the PlayStation 3 and
you have Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3
for the PS Vita and it doesn't support
cross play that'd be a perfect
opportunity to do it however they do
support DLC content like they said that
if you have Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3
DLC for the PlayStation 3 and you get
the PS Vita version your DLC content on
your PlayStation 3 can be ported over to
your PS Vita because they're like you've
already bought it why should you have to
buy it twice that is a big win for Sony
in my book I like the fact that they did
that usually in this gaming industry you
don't see a lot of freebies like that
and another cool feature is Remote Play
this is pretty much I think Sony's
answer to the Wii you know how one of
the main selling points of the Wii U is
that oh you can turn off your TV and
keep playing the game on the controller
he can pretty much do that with the PS
Vita you link your Vita to the
PlayStation 3 now you're playing it on
here your friends can watch whatever on
the TV as long as your PlayStation 3
remains on again though not a lot of
stuff supports it right now I popped him
at PlayStation 3 games that didn't
support it tried to play twisted metal
black cuz it was a free download when I
got twisted metal for the PlayStation 3
that didn't work hocked and Metal Gear
Solid for the PlayStation 1 that did
work a remote play is not a new thing
PSP had it but it was you know kind of
buggy and really abysmal it was pretty
miserable at least in my experience
anyway but on the PS Vita playing a
PlayStation 1 game on your Playstation 3
it's actually smooth this works with
downloaded PlayStation 1 games also you
don't have to be a lunatic like me that
still has your first generation version
at the PlayStation 3 but again that's if
I want to play a PlayStation 1 game what
I want is to be able to remotely play
PlayStation 3 games from my PS Vita that
would be the money I've heard you can do
it with layer of all the games layer and
I heard you can port downloaded PSP
games from your PlayStation 3 to your PS
Vita but I don't know cuz I didn't do
that then I thought can I port the
PlayStation 1 games over to the PS Vita
memory so I have it on my PlayStation
Vita I tried that with Metal Gear Solid
that didn't work then that got me to
thinking you should be able to
physically port more things from your
PlayStation 3 to your PS Vita like you
know those arcade games like The
Simpsons arcade game the x-men arcade
game if you
of those over to the PS Vita memory card
you can play those whenever and wherever
you are that would be awesome those
would be perfect for on-the-go gaming on
the PlayStation Vita because they take
like 15 to 20 minutes to be old-school
arcade games on the go that is win right
there so it seems like the PlayStation
Vita on what they want to do with it is
more potential than reality at the
moment but if they make it reality that
would be the coolest thing on earth they
make all these games compatible through
cross play make all these games
compatible through remote play and I got
the 3G version of the system also
because it came with a free 8 gig memory
card and that's not bad here's my
dilemma though I can either pay $30 a
month for two gigs of service per month
or I can get a 4G cellphone through my
cell phone provider I already have then
pay for the service to make my 4G cell
phone a wireless hotspot and Link my
Vita to that so I can have 4G on the go
anywhere I go 3G or 4G so I pretty much
got the 3G version for the free memory
card cuz that was cool so here is my
message to Sony a message that they
probably already knows Sony if you want
your PlayStation Vita to survive put all
your efforts into making cross play as
compatible as you possibly can with as
much stuff as you possibly can if you
are somehow allocating any funding to
curing the uncurable Japanese syphilis
and you're one step from doing it
Nixon take all those resources and make
cross play and remote play work because
casual gamers they don't need you and
they don't want you they have their cell
phones they play their Angry Birds and
they're really quick games on their cell
phones the cell phones have taken casual
gaming over they don't need it hardcore
gaming freaks like me to have
PlayStation 3s that might want cross
play and remote play that's it you need
to mark it too so make this [ __ ] work so
the PS Vita it looks great that's
undeniable
I like the interface however the main
selling points of it which are cross
play and remote play those need work if
they get those to working to get the
downloaded games on the PlayStation 3
workable on the PS Vita it would be a
powerhouse I hope that happens it's on
the table to happen I know they're
working on it they just hope it happens
soon so the PlayStation Vita have you
played it have you seen it are you
interested in it comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]